[Música]
bienvenidos al espacio de historia de
france 24 mi nombre es álvaro cordero el
intento de atentado del pasado 1 de
septiembre contra la vicepresidenta
argentina cristina fernández de kirchner
ha conmocionado a la política de esta
nación al representar el grado más
extremo de polarización que sufre
argentina desde hace años el intento de
magnicidio contra fernández de kirchner
es la tentativa de terminar con la que
quizá sea la figura política más
importante en esta nación austral en lo
que va de siglo y el pilar fundamental
del kirchnerismo junto con su marido
difunto néstor kirchner en france 24
repasamos la figura de la vicepresidenta
y analizamos su movimiento político el
kirchnerismo tal y como lo conocemos
surge a partir de la victoria
presidencial de néstor kirchner en el
año 2003 como tal este movimiento no se
empezó a llamar así hasta su llegada al
poder pero representa a toda la facción
izquierdista y contraria al
neoliberalismo enmarcada dentro del
amplio espectro que representa el
peronismo
tendencia ideológica que los hizo
triunfar tras la crisis de 2001 en
argentina
desde el sur del mundo y queremos fijar
junto a ustedes los argentinos
prioridades nacionales
y construir políticas de estado a largo
plazo para que de esa manera crear
futuro y generar tranquilidad
sabemos a dónde vamos
y sabemos a dónde no queremos ir o
volver
su gobierno pronto se caracterizó por la
apuesta por políticas más sociales y por
una mayor presencia del estado todo ello
con el objetivo de aliviar la complicada
situación económica que atravesaba
argentina entre sus políticas más
destacadas están la estatalización de
empresas de sectores clave para la
economía la ayuda social y económica a
los sectores más desfavorecidos o el
rechazo de políticas de libre mercado
programas acompañados de una defensa
fuerte de los derechos humanos en
especial al defender a las víctimas de
la dictadura y por la apuesta por una
fuerte coalición con otros líderes
progresistas en latinoamérica
políticas que resultaron un completo
éxito argentina canceló su deuda con el
fmi de forma anticipada y su economía
creció durante años en torno al 9% anual
datos que permitieron al kirchnerismo
forjar una amplia base de apoyo que los
mantuvo en el poder de nuevo en las
elecciones de 2007 aunque esta vez la
candidata fue la primera cristina
fernández de kirchner
presidenta acostúmbrense de todos
presidenta
[Aplausos]
yo sé que están todos
muy acostumbrados a los hombres pero
bueno que se acostumbren también a las
mujeres
cristina fernández continuó con las
políticas sociales y económicas de su
marido sin embargo el contexto global en
el que se dieron fue diferente al de su
marido ya que desde 2008 la crisis
mundial comenzó a afectar a argentina
aunque desde el kirchnerismo se continuó
apostando por propuestas como el control
de precios para combatir la inflación y
por la defensa del estado no es esto de
populismo o no populismo este rol tiene
que tener el estado en una determinada
sociedad si se cruza de brazos
y deja que las fuerzas del mercado
manejen y asignen bueno así no fue a los
argentinos y no vamos a permitir que
sigan saqueando el bolsillo de los
argentinos el final de su primer
gobierno estuvo marcado por la muerte de
néstor kirchner y aunque consiguió la
reelección en 2011 con más del 50% de
los votos la economía de la nación
argentina no mejoró esta situación hizo
que junto a varias polémicas los rivales
políticos de cristina fernández fuera y
dentro del peronismo aumentaran y que
aunque su popularidad se mantuvo alta
entre un sector de la población otra
parte comenzará a rechazarla un contexto
que empeoró aún más tras la muerte del
fiscal alberto nisman días después de
que denunciara un supuesto encubrimiento
de fernández en el marco del atentado
sobre la asociación mutual israelita
argentina de 1994 que dejó 85 fallecidos
una muerte que la oposición denunció
como asesinato y no suicidio y aunque
tiempo después se demostró que fernández
no tuvo nada que ver con ese atentado y
se rechazó la investigación las
incógnitas en torno a la misteriosa
muerte del fiscal continúan
cristina fernández no se presentó a las
elecciones de 2015 y su movimiento
cosechó su primera derrota frente al
derechista mauricio macri tras el
fracaso electoral cristina fernández se
convirtió en la principal figura de
oposición a macri desde su puesto como
senadora comenzó a reconstruir un
movimiento que pudiera derrotar al
entonces presidente en 2019 aunque
durante ese tiempo tampoco estuvo
ausente de polémica al enfrentar varios
juicios por corrupción que van desde la
asociación ilícita para defraudar dinero
público hasta el supuesto cobro de
sobornos casos que ella niega
es precisamente
atemorizar a los dirigentes de la
oposición quieren hacer callar a la
oposición en el cargo algo que no la
freno para volver al gobierno como
vicepresidenta junto con alberto
fernández y otros sectores peronistas
tras las elecciones de 2019 este último
periodo ha estado marcado por el
enfrentamiento entre el kirchnerismo
representado en la vicepresidenta y el
presidente fernández algo que junto a la
complicada situación económica la
oposición de la derecha y una nueva
investigación por corrupción contra
cristina han aumentado la polarización
política en argentina con esto
concluimos gracias por compartir y
comentar estas historias que las
encuentran en los programas de france 24
punto com
[Música]